talk about positive Kevin how you been
yeah are you always like that it's this
it's the things that I look at that are
so easy you're not just positive though
you look crazy ambitious that's the
thing that gets me about you in the rock
for sure it's like the ambitions off the
charts like I know your riches fuck like
when when do you think you got enough
you don't have enough there's no don't
know enough I don't have enough because
it's not over it's not over it's not
over so you know when when you put a cap
on it yeah you're putting a punctuation
to it mm-hmm and the the the ambition
comes from seeing what's out there
that can be obtained you know when you
see what's out there
like what can you mean physical things
like well you see what's out there when
you see where people are really gaining
wealth and knowledge from okay the
business relationships that you're able
to acquire the people that you're able
to partner with and create certain
things different revenue streams what I
found is as a young black guy from North
Philadelphia the biggest problem with
the biggest problem with in our
community is knowledge we don't know Dec
debt is welcomed because it's celebrated
that's all we know and I'm get that
credit card oh fuck that credit card up
and it is what it is they gotta figure
that out I ain't got it after that yeah
well you know what I'm getting student
loans they gave it to me then after that
shit is I'm figured out I put a cable
bill your name you put it in my name we
can switch it up whatever they do it
they were let's just put it in somebody
else name its welcome the Hustle is
welcome the knowledge of banks and what
you can do it can't do is it's fucking
you don't even get it
could you go to check cashing places
read like go check cash places because I
don't wanna go through that shift and
banks don't trust that go right there to
check heads please let me get my let me
get mine now take $30 whatever let me
get it the knowledge isn't given so it's
not to you obtain that knowledge and
understanding that you go oh shit oh
this is why you put money up Oh
this is this is how you increase versus
decrease oh this is how you earn on your
money oh wow I can gain wealth by
investing in what the stock world is
what how many people partake in a stock
world and is there a part that isn't
necessarily gambling is there a low risk
part these that's not the information
isn't there so that's why I got to a
certain level and a certain group of
people where I got it and now that I got
it I want to give it so now I'm gonna
give it I'm gonna give it to the people
that I know need it most and for me that
younger generation of black people that
don't understand the cool thing is in
financial longevity not in the now
it's not in the moment for jewelry not
in a moment for the car it's in the
longevity is in building so at the end
of the day you can say look at what I
have look at what I worked for look at
what I have that's mine
monopoly is real but you have to have
the financial understanding and I teamed
up I got chased on then we're doing
something called financial fitness
where's just about me educating people
on money how to manage money how do how
to be smart with your money but it's
coming from a person that fucked up
money I didn't always understand it I
hold in taxes before because I didn't
understand it in the beginning
I've had bad credit credit cards
wouldn't take me because I mixed up
whatever I've been there I've done it
thank God I was able to fix it and get
on the right path and now that I have
the knowledge I want to give it could
simply don't know so when you say the
end game the end game is getting to a
point where I've taken all the knowledge
that I've been able to get over these
years and really applying it and
providing family wealth when it's all
said and done the last name heart is
gonna mean just more a lot more than
just Kevin Hart a comedy heart beat
production it's got heartbeat digital
you got heartbeat ventures your
heartbeat real estate there's so many
things that the last name heart will be
attached to you're so real estate Kevin
Hart doesn't sell real estate a buy real
estate you talk about yourself
I'll buy it but the reason why is
because investment investment but but as
you get older you learn this you learn
it and and you know it's such a thing
where you talk about black versus white
you know a lot of people do that and and
I flee so like there is racism racism
exists I'm not unaware of that but there
is a high volume of it that's that's
non-existent people had a good people
and when you can merge yourself with
good people and follow the paths that
you see that these good successful
people have taken you didn't become a
part of a world and group that nobody
expected you to be it so for me I now
have the position to do that
and take all of these relationships and
all this knowledge and take it back to
the people that need it most
I like to share I don't want it all by
myself now are you doing this and the
financial stuff you're doing this in
videos you like released not a videos no
we're gonna start we're gonna start
financial fitness like I said would
chase JPMorgan Chase Jamie Dimon very
good guy to Shonda is well they're their
help leading in charge of saying how can
we get to the people that we feel need
the financial information of most so I
said put me out there like let's let's
go directly to the consumer so from
colleges from high schools senior
classes junior classes going out and
talking to people before they go into
the next stages of their life a lot of
things that you should know so you're
gonna speak to them and just share
personal information are you gonna put
this stuff online as well yeah yeah
you'll be able to track and find content
from it but I'm authentic so I said the
best way to really do it is to put me in
a position to be heard right I want to
be heard like like it's a different
story what I explained to the the people
of JPMorgan Chase just when we were
talking about this and as an amazing
board of people that are just figuring
this out and the best way to go and do
it and I said you can't have the white
guy that's never been to the hood or
who's not from the hood or has no idea
how the economy works here in what the
real troubles are
you can't throw that man in the
situation to talk to people because I'm
not listening to you from the gate
because you don't relate I don't relate
to you but throwing somebody in a
situation that's lived it that's been in
it that's been fucked up in it made it
out of it and it's now coming back to
help run it's a different ballgame and
that's what I want to be and you know we
have other voices outside of myself very
powerful voices that are going to do it
as well but the purpose is to align
ourselves to really make a change so you
can either be the conversation about
making change you can be actual a part
of the action to do it I want to be a
part of the action and in doing it
you'll also be able to understand my
drive you'll get why I do so much
you'll get why my hand is then so much
because I have access to it and the
question should be why not yeah the
question shouldn't be yeah why is he
doing everything he should be why aren't
you why aren't you trying to do
everything why not